5 17 on your Finally Friday well what's
cool at school
c-o-n-g-r-a-t-s to some of the best
spellers in the Clark County School
District
after starting with 45 young men and
women at Vegas PBS the other day it was
no hallucination that the top seven
spellers in sixth seventh and eighth
grades learned that there's no
abbreviation for good diction on an
occasion when the frequency of fun words
like macaroni was hermetically sealed in
whimsical
pandemonium
wow okay so those 21 students are going
to spell down to the top two in each
grade level at next month's CCSD finals
to move on to the state be next year
with one winner going on to represent
Nevada in the National Spelling Bee we
always want to know what's cool is cool
you got something let us know cool at
school under the Community tab of our
website or just email cool at school at
8newsnow.com could you handle Whimsical
pandemonium pandemonium boy there's a
lot of there's a lot of little twists
and turns in some of those
reciprocity oncology wow that was a
plethora of complicated words
easier to write it out you know than to
verbalize it well even saying your name
can age you know sometimes you have to
think about it the kids have different
techniques some of them pretend that
they're writing you can see some of them
imagining letters okay that I that's
what I would have to do